bethenny celebrated her 18th birthday
with her family it was a happy time but
becoming a young adult forced a damaging
and drastic change to her autism care
and led to being locked up in solitary
confinement for 24 hours a day in a
windowless room Beth is in a Cell
Bethenny's locked away
she can't have human contact and she's
not getting any support Bethenny's not
in a good place
people send things and I get everything
from from lovely cards with jokes in
following a public outcry after Beth's
treatment was exposed the Department of
Health and Social Care ordered an
investigation it highlights systemic
failure and makes a list of improvements
to force fundamental change to the
system the report recognized a lack of
appropriate home-like community
provision it recommends a national
policy to ensure that seclusion or
segregation is only utilized as a last
resource and it concludes that no
children with autism should be admitted
to a mental health hospital in the
absence of a mental health need speaking
on the caber Lea show care Minister
Caroline Dynegy offered her apology to
Jeremy
of course I'm sorry do you accept the
minister's apology Jeremy not at all not
at all quite tellingly this report
accepts it hasn't made any new findings
as these have previously been identified
across many reviews when can she expect
to be held by her father again well I
mean we want to get Bethany out as soon
as possible but it would be utterly
irresponsible for me to discharge her
just because there's a huge pressure on
me to do so into a setting which is only
going to make matters worse for this
very vulnerable young lady this report
into Beth's care coincides with a wider
government announcement for plans to
improve training for all health and
social care workers for autism and
learning disabilities it also says it
will review the discharge plan for
everyone and the 2,000 people with
autism and learning disabilities held in
a mental health you
people like Beth trapped inside a broken
system
Ashish Joshi Sky News